- Did your parents, were they encouraging
with you singing or were they,
cause my mom was an
educator so she was kind of
slightly like, "Hmm, I
think you should maybe
still go to college." Like, were your
parents encouraging?
- Yes. (laughs)
I think, I mean they were
definitely encouraging
but I think my dad
especially was a little bit
more skeptical of the, you know,
this whole thing as a
career, I think because
my whole family was like
so far removed from like,
anything to do with the industry.
Like they didn't know what it was,
they didn't think it
was, like, a real thing
that you could do with your life.
And, I mean, realistically
it doesn't happen to everyone
so I did get really lucky but,
yeah they were definitely,
you know, try to
persuade me to, like, go to
college and do the whole, like,
take the educational route, but,
thankfully this happened
before I could do that so,
(laughs) it worked out.
- That's awesome, (laughs) that's amazing.
So what kind of music
did your parents like
when you were young?
Like, cause your sound
is really rad and I was
think it's interesting to know people's,
I was the youngest in my family so I had
all these different
influences coming at me,
so what were your
parents, like, what music
did you grow up around?
- Well my mom listened to
a lot of Italian music.
We're Italian, so she, you
know, was born and raised there,
so she played a lot of Italian music.
And then my dad played a lot
of, like, traditional, like,
you know Beatles and
Queen and I'm not even
just saying this, because it's you,
right now, but he loved your album.
Like, we, I grew up on you.
- Oh, that's awesome.
- Just because, like my dad,
like, we went on this
road trip, we were like
driving to Florida and
that's the only thing
he played for the entirety of the two days
that we were driving and I--
- Okay he is amazing.
- I loved it.
(Kelly laughs)
No, I loved it,
I mean I love your music, I would've
listened to it anyways but
like my dad was obsessed
with your first album.
- I love how random that is.
That's amazing.
- I know, I swear to god,
like I'm not even just saying that.
I know your entire first
album off by heart,
cause of my dad, so,
there you go.
- Well what's funny though is
you mentioned your mother
loved Italian music.
That's cool that your
mom was listening to that
when you had that in your
ear, like growing up.
Not every kid gets that.